Let's talk about kids with sensory issues,
why they're not just misbehaving.
So for my daughter, her triggers are textures and clothes.
And I had similar issues growing up,
but we just didn't really know what it was.
And this is bigger than just
her not wanting to wear certain type of clothing.
It's her body actually can't stand the way it feels.
For me, when I was a kid,
it was so bad that even if I was naked right out of the shower,
I still wanted to claw my skin off cause I was so uncomfortable.
To put it in perspective,
imagine you're in a straight jacket full of sand
and the person who put you in that straight jacket tells you,
stop misbehaving, just deal with it.
You would feel unheard, crazy,
uncomfortable and desperate.
And that's what these kids are experiencing.
Her brain isn't processing these tactile stimulations in a correct way.
And she's not doing it on purpose.